you're kind of like Loki in shape now
Wow like I mean people mark like and
then you're like oh he's like like
working out like what's the what's going
on here well I cut back on the sauce it
was a real booze bag and then I was
always just rotten fruit you know I was
just do II so I said I'll go to the gym
once a week and that's it you just go
once you go once a week I used to box I
got really into boxing for a while with
my trainer guy fell off we'll get to
that later
but and I was like I don't want to meet
a new guy and all that so I just gave up
on the boxing thing but now I just do
little dumb tricks I you know when
you're on the subway I just lift my feet
off the ground it's like a little OCD
thing that gets the ABS going
there's always time to do I do weird
squats in the morning I do what I call
bed jumps you know I'm in a hotel room
so often that I'll just jump from the
floor to the bed 30 times which doesn't
sound that crazy but it really gets the
the core burnin mm-hmm you gonna get
those knees up so give it a whirl if you
ever get feeling chunky and what about
one of the squats what are the squats
you did well I have weirds I have weird
I have zero thigh I have no thigh meat
it's just just femur and is that Famer
yeah it's just Famer and so I just go up
and down you know like and I do that 50
times and that burns and you squeeze
your butt on the way up I've seen all
these thing I saw this on YouTube and I
just stole it but I mean I hotel room so
much and I have to like I have to do
like prison workout kind of [ __ ] mm-hmm
yeah you act like you're not doing
anything and then you just rattled off
like four things I guess you're right
but those only take like three minutes
each so I made it out I'm done in half
an hour
you do that you said once a week but is
it I do that every day and that shame I
go once a week oh okay so you're doing
something I'm doing so I just feel some
guilt about the food I eat I still drink
a lot of whiskey and bourbon so I got to
do something and you know I'm watching
my friends like a friends who were
hitting their fort their 40s and they're
they're slowly dying yeah so I'm scared
of that I'm 35 now so I got to get
cooking
yeah that's why I'm I'm 31 and like I'm
at the tipping point where it's like
alright you can't just get away with
anything or it starts to kind of yeah
karma will hit you it hits you [ __ ]
like I used to just drink a hundred
beers not a hundred but I just drink a
bunch of beers all night I would just
drink and now I'm like oh that beer is
this many calorie it's like I hate it
I'm that guy but you got to worry but
have you seen an uptick in your
professional success as your health has
I think so yeah I've noticed that yeah
look at like John Mulaney Dan Soder Joe
list all these guys got sober and just
took off yeah
so I I like booze too much to quit so I
just said all right I'm just gonna tamp
it down a little bit and not just black
out four nights a week but let's look at
drunk
I just want blackout so that's so I have
my little what do you call it
compromises okay you'll still drink but
you have the self-control tonight yeah I
mean I had three whiskey's last night
Thursday and lived it up and then you
just brought chicken fingers I'm eating
that so you know I'm still living
goddammit